yeah hello and welcome to the video
playing boom boom again from Sweden he
completely killed me in the recent game
with black I had black in some little
pest so I hope to do better this time
Kings Indian I would be pretty happy
about my position have been getting with
the petroleum systems fantastic relief
so let's see what boom boom is doing
against the main line and I'm not yet
completely sure about the move order one
system with them with 28 first and and
so on there many move all the things
here does he have a 4 here maybe I light
a fourth always interesting against that
ok doesn't happen so p1 maybe I'm
getting away with before in blue moon
now ok so here 95 is the thing I'm going
to play it and see how he covers his
seven means not that that he cannot do
it but 9 a-6 he has to worry about a for
hanging at some point so ok currently
with his bishops is attacking my night
so it's not happening all that quickly
still ok still he didn't do not a sec so
what's going on here
what about 35 going for concrete play
quickly knew that sell that that's the
move tool to try to punish black for not
playing night to a six and we shouldn't
forget that development wise I'm in
great shape you have got much better
development so this six was my idea I'm
not sure if this works the IDS Bishop is
a Bishop c4 of course we should see for
immediately don't know but t-6s Cody six
Wow hello a quick answer I really
thought I mean I would be pretty
terrified if someone throws these six at
me and he just plays the move okay so
night see force one move I can also take
you should see for Bishop e6 might still
be okay for him and so I go here that
was selected much more interesting
anyway attacking me fire and intending
to take c 7 and 10 96 now what is she is
is why it opens up the position like I
do now next position is full of holes
like g6 and everything is kind of loose
and that is oftentimes on getting
getting problematic so here i am just
threatening 95 and over here and then
Bishop c4 that should should be very
strong so how is he defending against it
another idea is just to take c7 and then
96 stuff
hmm well if i just take this let's just
keep it simple maybe I have something
bad of it this looks simple and good
okay soon yeah wondering i like CD 64
Bishop c4 Alex looks straight it looks
strong but
I'm not sure how strong it is it looks
good but what Bishop e3 now which is
definitely a bit irritating
okay hmm maybe we should have to simply
training it the first comes to d4 of it
the bishop on h4 is actually not a bad
piece of course yeah yeah here you
should see for I can also take that
let's do this first the bishop is strong
now and now take here and play a form
that that opens up the position Queen h5
is coming now that's what I meant with
this position being very loose so 97 but
if that's not a threat yeah there is no
threat here I take this it's probably
simple simple input threatening that
takes d4 now and if it takes Bishop
takes wet that's falling apart I don't
believe it Knight takes is also not bad
okay we should takes
and now just take andy sixx maybe not
the best continuation but it can hardly
be bad for for white
yeah the porn looks very suks very
strong I don't see any good counter play
them probably just look in one next okay
take that cebu sorry and we should be
seven monkey one let's go okay one so
how to play Emily I just keep this and
then see what what happens I mean I can
improve the position I don't I mean you
really cannot do all that much in black
way down jump it's pretty pretty
hopeless yeah that turn that was again a
very good position all of this opening
I'm really not sure about the move over
the caf okay we are here the engine
already gives c5 devastating black has
no development down at me that that
shouldn't be underestimated so that was
even stronger c5 again was strongly I I
ultimately played it but only after some
other moves yeah it's just a full-scale
invasion on all those weeks square so
because Bishop d8 is very funny here
keeping this bond and also stopping the
rooks hear it for being connected it's
very nice yes okay but also not very
human so I just hope that oops I just
hope that I had a position that was ok
maybe not keeping my advantage from what
I think I did always on this + 2 + 3
kind of kind of levels yeah yeah black
has to know stuff there i mean just
playing whatever it's not working
against this opening you need to get
play some theoretical lines i think
otherwise it's just um to lose this
position ok guys thanks for watching